من كان يعلم أن دونالد ترامب بالكاد
ستجعل أمريكا تقرأ مرة أخرى ،
فقد ألهم عددًا كافيًا من الكتب لملء
مكتبة رئاسية العديد منها يبدأ
بـ F هناك حريق وغضب بوب
وودوارد سبير هذا الكتاب في Woodward هو
إجمالي إنه ضفدع كلي و
دانيلز كتاب جديد عاصف  الكشف الكامل ، نعتقد
أنه يفضل القسم L
من المكتبة كتاب الشعور بالرضا مثل كتاب
القاضي جانين الكاذبين والسيد
الليبراليين
.  الرئيس الذي تعرفه بعد 18 شهرًا
لم تكن مربية أي نوع من الإشارة إلى أي
تواطؤ ، لا يوجد تصادم ، لا
مكالمات هاتفية ، لم أجري مكالمات هاتفية ، لا اجتماعات ،
لا شيء قد يكون ترامب مسؤولاً
عن زيادة بنسبة 4٪ في مبيعات الكتب غير الروائية
وفقًا لأحد التقارير  هذا الأسبوع ، إذا
كان هناك أرضية أمامه ، فنحن سعداء ،
لذا تفضل واستمتع بكتاب جيد
من مكتبة ترامب الرئاسية الشاسعة والمتوسعة ،
ولكن قبل أن ترسل تحذيرًا سريعًا
للقراء ، لذلك كنت مثلي.  سأكتب
كل شيء وإدراجه بعض هذه
الكتب ليست آمنة للعمل
وربما حتى لغرفة نومك